all right so you brought your son to set
with you while shooting right I always
do my son's almost 5 and both of me and
my husband are both directors so he's
kind of grown up going to sets and he
gave a little tip sometimes to Tom like
Oh Tom Hanks yeah sometimes he was like
you know I like what you're doing I
think you need a rocket ship I'm was
like okay great great rod else shouts
tell me what else
two directors that's amazing yeah that
has got to be a fun relationship ma'am
it is it means we understand each
other's work yeah we know the other ones
going through and really cool Oh any
time must be great for Wiley like what
did mom say last night right well in my
[Laughter]
household as well how did this movie
make you reflect on your own life well I
mean like you I grew up watching mr.
Rogers but I think the thing about mr.
Rogers is it's also we watched it when
we were so little it's almost like in
our DNA
it's like pre memory so I feel like I
got to rediscover mr. Rogers as a
grown-up and as a parent you know it's a
different thing to look at the show now
and to see it through the eyes of a
grown person and recognize oh wow he's
talking about things a lot of us still
need to work on I mean literally my
husband and I sat and sobbed in our
bedroom watching this film because I
married close to my heart cuz I didn't
grow up with the father so for a lot of
us to bother figure you know I've had so
many people say that to me that they
almost actually believed mr. Rogers was
their dad when they yeah that's or it
was somebody that you wanted you thought
that's what it should be like you know
and I just you did a really great job
bill and Joanne Joanne Rogers his wife
and Bill who was his right-hand man for
his whole life said something to me the
other day in Pittsburgh where they said
you know Fred didn't expect everybody to
live in his image he accepted us with
all our imperfections he knew we weren't
perfect parents he knew we weren't
perfect people like something is freeing
about recognizing both that Fred was a
human being he wasn't a saint and that
he didn't expect us to be Saints either
you know he he didn't shy away from the
hard parts of being alive and being a
human being and now is actually one of
my favorite parts in the film is when
his wife does
say he has to work at this this isn't
like she said that to me that's in the
movie because she said that all of this
because I'm like if you just come out
being awesome and lovely well great
that's easy for you but like if you
knowing you had to work at it like we
all have to work at it it takes effort
it's like to take time to listen to
other people and empathize with them it
takes more work one funny thing I found
about this though is it I heard Tom
Hanks turn this role down like a few
times you did but then somehow you roped
him in how did you rope him in and can I
know your secret never do anything so
miraculous again in my life the story is
that I met I'm friends with Tom Hanks
his son Collin oh ok and we met Tom and
I met at a backyard birthday party where
all the kids were playing in the
backyard and we were talking and he said
Oh what do you do and I said well I'm a
director and he said oh there was just
this article in The New York Times this
weekend about women directors in
Hollywood and I said yeah I'm in that
article Tom Hanks standing there how
cool did you feel to be like actually
I'm in the article and he said I'll
watch your movie in a week later he
personally emailed me and said I watched
her movie let's get together in chat and
that's the other thing about him is he
doesn't have like someone reached out to
you like he reaches out to you and says
so cool and so he must have loved your
work and you kept in touch for years and
when I signed on to this movie the
producer said Tom Hanks has always been
our dream mr. Rodgers but he's passed on
the movie three times he said no and I
said well I I could try and I reached
out to him and he'll signed on right
away you're magic
rayful perfect he is the casting was
perfect the directing was amazing I'm
not everybody who worked on this movie
worked on this movie because they loved
it
and you ready to see the camera yeah you
can feel it and it matters that Dad or
matter you know I really believe you
don't have to suffer to make good art
yes oh I love you I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this